je me suis rendu compte que d'un truc
c'est que quand il sera sur scène et que
jean seront ainsi elle sera beaucoup
plus grande que tout le monde
[Musique]
moi je m'en fous de la taille la couleur
la forme la différence quand on veut
quand on aime quand on nous aime rien
n'est impossible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'avis de mimi c'est un roman une
histoire qui commence à lyon
[Musique]
elle revient chaque mois bon pour voir
ses parents ce voyage de juin encore
plus symbolique que les autres sa plus
jeune soeur frédérique vient d'entrer en
clinique pour mettre au monde son
premier enfant
je vous rappelle tout à l'heure mais a
tout de suite
bien passé
16h30
et donc du 28 juin
les paris ils arrivent ils à louper
d'entrée papa et sa réponse
[Rires]
[Musique]
est on pour trente ans je fais les yeux
et bien comme ça que c'est le goût du
[Musique]
jeu c'est de nettoyer
car il interdit à des fossiles
lema ti sont plus qu'une famille une
tribu au sens tendre du monde le grand
chef c'est mariette la grand mère
paternelle
elle a été résistante épicière marchande
de berlingots sur les foires
correspondante d'un journal local à 84
ans elle vit une retraite active ici à
trésors dans l'ain
[Musique]
[Rires]
je suis pas dupe il jeune homme de la
maison
en effet légal avant d'avoir des
bouleaux femme
mimi est arrivé à la clinique saint
joseph à lyon je suis allée la voir le
lendemain
et j'ai tout de suite eu un choc
j'ai vu sa brassière retourner
en quatre fois
je l'avais pas vue des fêtes
mais j'ai pas pensé à son cas
je dis bon il ya quelque chose qu'est ce
que c'est
puis mon fils me dit mon encontre stm
dit tu sais tu vas l'avoir jolie ma
petite fille mais hier j'ai cru que
j'avais un petit monstre qu'il sait
peut-être pas empêche le cces 16 et ça a
duré plusieurs mois sa maman l'a mené à
la visite où on lui disait que tout
était bien et c'est vrai que c'était un
beau bébé qui poussait très bien
normalement au point de vue
corps d'un point de vue membres alors
mon fils ne s'inquiétait pas il il avait
toujours un petit choc quand elle
rentrait mais du fait que sa femme lui
disait bon bain tout va bien
ne cherchez pas plus loin
et je les menées chez le pédiatre a book
pendant mes deux couples partis se
promener à grenoble où j'ai souvenir est
resté
je suis allé chez le pédiatre et un
moment où il m'a vu
il m'a dit madame vous avez un petit nom
de choses ces mamies qui l'a appris un
mot que nous n'avons jamais bien re
prononcer je croirais non
pourquoi cet amour c à vous qui vous
paraît tabou
je sais pas si ça s'appelle ça peut
s'appeler tabou mais quand on y pense et
dans la famille c'est un petit peu dur
le mot mais par exemple un exemple que
je fais du scrap jamais je mettrais
même sur le scrabble et si quelqu'un
mais je ne dis rien mais enfin ça me
fait quelque chose
je voudrais juste risqué une petite
question parce que c'était la première
question qui se pose est au départ il ya
une carrière qui marche bien une famille
formidable ce qui manque pas le bébé
comme en histoire et
c'est vrai que maintenant ça me dit est
de plus en plus parce que je me dis bon
en plus il ya une question d'âge et 37
ans j'ai vraiment pas envie de passer à
côté de la maternité parce que c'est
quelque chose de fabuleux
et que c'est quelque chose que je
ressens en tout cas il y en a qui
peuvent ne pas le ressentir alors c'est
vrai qu'il me restera l'adoption mais
j'aimerais connaître cette joie de je
suis une femme sur cette jeune femme
professionnellement parlant une femme
amicalement parlant et j'aimerais
connaître cette joie d'être une femme de
porter un bébé si je passe si je peux
pas si ça se trouve pas si je peux pas
en faire un je le ferais pas mais je en
adopterai j'ai pas envie de rester sans
enfants autour de moi j'ai pas envie de
me retrouver à 60 ans comme une
andouille j'ai trouvé chez ma magnifique
de ma grand mère avec ses enfants et ses
petits enfants donc si c'est pas les
miens bio jeunes biologiquement ce sera
des miens
ce sera les mêmes et par le choeur
biologiquement il ya un petit risque
on a un risque sur il ya une chance sur
deux que je met au monde un enfant comme
moi mais maintenant on peut le on peut
le savoir et c'est vrai que je ne
mettrai pas au monde un enfant comme moi
moi j'ai assumé ce que j'étais parce que
psion parce que j'avais un entourage tel
qu'il était parce que j'avais une
famille équilibrée parce que j'avais des
vraiment un cocon qui m'a protégé de
tout ce qui aurait pu me blesser
tout en mouvement sur la vie en mettant
pas à l'abri de ce qui peut blesser mais
cette force de caractère que j'ai je ne
suis pas sûr qu'un enfant que mon enfant
l'aura donc c'est vrai je ne mettrai pas
au monde un enfant comme ça fait hurler
pourtant je le dis parce que on dit mais
vous vous en êtes bien sorti pourquoi
pas pour vous mais moi je ne sais pas si
j'aurai la force de lui donner tout ce
qu'on m'a donné à moi je suis ton avis
mimi a puisé sa force dans une enfance
qui ressemble aux photos de doisneau
l'été vous ne croiserez pas à saint
tropez ou dans les soirées huppées de la
riviera elles passent chaque année ici à
l'île rousse en corse des vacances
tranquilles dans la maison des fugueurs
ils sont amis depuis 1976 et un concert
à lyon du big bazar le mit et et
groupies fidèle des premiers rangs elle
rêvait d'entrer dans la troupe michel et
stéphanie l'ue ont fermement conseillé
de finir sa licence de sciences éco
avant d'apprendre le métier de
saltimbanque
[Musique]
le gain était vraiment le premier
tremplin quand il m'a mis le pied à
l'étrier
il s'est pas dix ans la pauvre les
petites faut qu'on apprenne dans l'école
ça lui fera plaisir j'ai fait ma b 1 il
m'a dit ok tu veux faire ça mais tu
seras star ou rien t'as pas le droit
tapas le ch n'a pas le choix ou tu seras
une merde qui fera des castings toute sa
vie et qu'on mettra comme fou du roi il
sait pas ce que tu veux ou tu seras
quelqu'un les gens diront
celle là on en avait besoin n'existait
pas c'est pas du tout prétentieux ses
danses et ses danses et moi les miens
que je le dis et c'est vrai qu'il m'a
appris à être complaisantes a pas me
dire je suis petit excusez moi prenez
moi tels que je fais et m'a dit tu dois
les encore plus que tout le monde
sait si les termes de michel etc ça
correspond tout à fait à ça elle m'a dit
'il ne te ne te prends pas en pis tu es
toi-même mais bouge toi bouge-toi bouge
toi et est pas tout le monde tu peux
faire que ça tue faut pas que les gens
disaient les gentilles un grand fan
gentil oui elle est pas mal faut que ce
soit très bien jamais pas mal ou pas
être moyenne
[Musique]
la corse c'est aussi louis un copain
photographe qui organise la pétanque les
parts ou pêche ou les fêtes
[Musique]
j'avais filmé us
mon agenda
[Musique]
à
mi mât
tuyaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
midi sonne dans un grand appartement à
part quand vous lui demandez ce qu'il
agace dans la vie de tous les jours elle
parle des rayons trop dans les
supermarchés des distributeurs de cartes
bleues inaccessible et enchaîne tout de
suite sur les vrais handicaps plus grave
que les quelques centimètres qui lui
manque
c'est quoi la mëme c'est votre vie qui
défile
c'est tous les cas les photos pour et
c'est un peu ma vie qui défile puisque
c'est tout le cahier photos qu'on va
mettre dans le livre qui sort et c'est
vrai que c'est sympa
soumette un choix pour l'instant
j'approuve totalement ça fait drôle de
regard et pour pas les copines et époque
où est
le plus beau moment je dis alors le plus
beau moment c'est ce qui va lire
autrement ce serait porter la vie
est le plus moche plus moi je me
rappelle plus
non c'est
plus moche
yonhap aller plus loin chez quelques
fait quelques pas bon mais c'est pas de
napa qui bat le record pour l'instant il
est encore pas là non plus tôt j'espère
qu'il m'a oublié qu'une bougie qu'est ce
qui vous fait mal
la tolérance la tolérance au sens large
c'est-à-dire de le non respect de ce
qu'on a en face de soi c'est ça qui peut
faire mal à tous les niveaux aussi bien
au niveau perso
au niveau personnel privé qu'au niveau
général professionnel je crois que c'est
celle là tolérance et englobe le fait de
juger sans connaitre le fait de juger
sans prendre le temps d'approfondir je
crois que ça peut être très grave et je
paie je parle pas d'eux pour moi c'est
ce qui déclenche des guerres c'est ce
qui déclenche comme ses skis des plantes
d
punch aux points
j'ai peur d'être seule ville
j'ai pas peur d'être seule parce que je
crois qu'on a la solitude qu'on mérite
moi je suis entouré j'ai des amis je
pense que vraiment que si on est tout
seul c'est que c'est qu'on n'a pas fait
ce qu'il fallait pour être entouré la
solitude pour moi c'est un c'est une
qu'on n'a peut-être pas donné assez et
moi je pense pas tout seul c'est pas que
je donne beaucoup je procède prétention
mais on donne beaucoup et je donne aussi
donc partir du moment où il ya un
échange mais pas solitude et puis la
solitude c'est ça ça se travaille moi
j'ai pas envie de travailler ça je
travaille moi je compte travailler au
contraire le
l'entourage travail et d'amitié je
travaille l'amour la tendresse
elle vieillir quand à ça c'est un autre
problème sérieux nous passent tous le
tuteur sera le mieux on m'a dit je
vivrais très bien il ferait longtemps
que
[Musique]
les crèmes antirides la solitude des
cadres à célibataire les tests pour
rencontrer l'âme soeur voilà les thèmes
des sketches écrits avec palmade pour le
spectacle au splendid
à savourer c'est un métier
or là carrément la deûle à 2000 ils ont
travaillé ou moins ensemble pour mettre
au point ce récital solo d'une heure
trente
[Rires]
voilà vous êtes parfait on le joue un
tout petit peu palmade résume cette
expérience en expliquant que mimi lui a
pris un nouvel humour celui qui fait
rire sans se moquer
ne reste qu'un plus
[Musique]
et
m
le succès de la fille aînée n'a rien
changé dans la vie des matis tous les
lundis marcel répète avec l'harmonie un
cortège de saxe du jazz la seule folie
de cet homme de rigueur de foi et de
principe qui n'a jamais fait de
différence entre ses trois enfants les
pèlerinages à lourdes le charlatan les
méchantes langues effacée à la gomme un
mauvais souvenir
[Musique]
j'ai très très souvent eu envie de
je faisais les points c'est mimi qui
très souvent ne disait pas par un reste
quand même rester calme j'aurais
effectivement si c'est une dame une mémé
ça passait encore mais quelqu'un le
grand gaillard bien bâti qui savent
qu'ils appesanti c'est son regard que je
tu accèdes malsain en fait le pauvre
gars étaient bien plus mal à l'aise que
moi elle avoue j'ai eu souvent envie de
rentrer notre choix c'est de gagner
mimi s'est largement inspiré de sa vie
pour écrire le rôle de la même raconté
en fiction l'histoire d'une femme
qu'elle connaît bien faire comprendre à
des millions de téléspectateurs que la
différence n'existe que dans le regard
des autres
une sorte de psychanalyse télévisuelle
qui reviendra en décembre sur les écrans
jédir action oui vous allez compté
jusqu'à 3 d'accord et a3 vous allez
arriver mimi en tête donc voilà prend la
baloche
tu sais aujourd'hui de t'occuper les
autres médias
le titre a changé on ne parle plus d'une
nounou mais d'une nana qu'ont les autres
qui rêve d'amour de mariage et d'enfants
je lis ressemble de plus en plus à
minuit
les premiers flirts et l'adolescence et
au même âge que tout le monde joue c'est
un petit peu plus tard c'est plus tard
moi j'ai échappé hélas je rêvais de me
faire rouler des pelles là sous les
portes cochères mais bon un gamin de mon
âge n'a pas failli à l'époque quand on a
15 end année un gamin d'une quinzaine
d'années n'est pas forcément capable
d'accepter ce que je suis là gianni mal
à s'accepter lui-même en pleine crise
d'adolescence il va pas en plus
supporter la mienne et c'est vrai que
c'est venu plus tard parce que j'ai tout
vécu en blu à 20 ans mais j'avais
attendu vingt ans j'allais pas je n'ai
pas perdre de temps donc c'est venu plus
tard ce genre j'en ai souffert comme
comme comme on peut souffrir quand on
quand on marche pas comme on veut mais
pas au point de d'en souffrir trop quand
même
[Musique]
les coups durs les amours déçues ses
secrets mimi n'en parle qu'à ses seuls
la nia nia nia
marib est la cadette ville à vaison la
romaine avec ses deux enfants et joue
les complices les gardes du corps les
confidences quand sa soeur a du mal à
gérer son trop plein d'émotions
qu'est ce que vous ressentez quand elle
entre en scène fait plein de choses y
aller là on qui viennent aux yeux ça
c'est sûr de se dire c'est elle qui
hélas est elle
elle a réussi à faire tout ce chemin
n'est pas évident elle avait pas tous
les atouts au départ il manquait
sûrement quelque chose mais justement
les quelques centimètres qu'il nous
manquait au départ ma elle en a fait
elle en a fait sa force et elle s'est
battue et c'est vrai que moi je à chaque
spectacle quand les gens applaudissent à
la fin et se lève et je moi je suis en
larmes je finis vent la frangine là et
c'est vrai que ça fait chaud au coeur ça
fait quelque chose
est ce que vous vous souvenez quand vous
étiez petit un moment vous allez poser
la question à vous parents ou à
quelqu'un de savoir pourquoi elle était
plus petit que vous
je me souviens assez tard en avoir parlé
avec ma main joue comme ça savoir
comment c'était venu comme il s'en était
rendu compte mais franchement je me suis
jamais dit je crois pas je crois ça m'a
jamais ça m'a jamais choqué je me
rappelle avoir ouvert les portes avant
elle je me revois ouvrir une porte alors
qu'elle n'y arrivait pas mais jamais non
ça m'a c'était tout naturel où ma soeur
était plus petit que moi c'est tout
c'était c'est comme ça c'est même un peu
plus tard avec frédéric cantin
envoyer les gens se retourner dans la
rue sur elle marchait avec frédéric
minier continue avec frédéric on se
retournait et qu'on leur tirait la
langue en ça nous énerve est parce que
pour nous c'était notre frangine et
c'est tout avec le plus petit que les
autres mais ça n'a aucune importance moi
j'aurais rêvé avoir un grand frère
j'aurais adoré avoir un grand frère
peut-être parce que je suis content
parce que j'ai besoin que de ce fait
pour ça que j'ai toujours je me suis
toujours profiter sur des hommes grands
costauds sont souvent blond aux yeux
bleus peut faire mal à personne ici
et c'est vrai que je recherche dans les
hommes ce que m'apporte pas mes copines
le mousseur c'est à dire une force une
sécurité je tombe pas toujours sur des
mecs qui m'apporte ça mais j'ai besoin
de ça j'ai besoin d'un homme comme même
mais d'un dur enfin pu réaliser il n'y a
pas de prince charmant
s'il est très discret pour l'instant
j'attends et je sais qu'il va arriver
mais je guette je ne n'ai pas encore lu
il ya eu des princes qu'il n'est pas
tout charmant le prince charmant avec un
grand p annoncé l'arrivée en suspens
[Musique]
j'ai des kilos en trop j'ai plein de
choses qui vont pas gd centimètres en
moins g mais bon si on assume ce qu'on
est je crois que c'est le meilleur moyen
de faire que d autres se disent pourquoi
je suis pas comme elle m'a le plus beau
compliment qu'on m'a fait c'est une dame
qui est venu me voir en me disant ma
fille elle m'a sa petite fille de quatre
ans lui a dit quand je serai grande je
veux être mimie mathy je trouve ça
génial moi ça prouve que j'ai gagné
quelque chose j'ai pas gagner sur tous
les plans mais mais il ya quelque chose
qui est passé qui est qui et qui
est chouette quoi les gamins dit je veux
être comme toi plus tard elle lui a même
dit plus tard je vais te gêne je trouve
simplement vides à moi alors que l'aisne
avant c'était bien la méchante naine la
vilaine maintenant ça peut être venir un
mot joli bas c'est génial si un gamin à
l'illusion de devenir comme moi j'ai
vraiment gagner qu'il faut
[Musique]